sa veille et le tout toujours le temps
dans toutes les campagnes des
présidentielles l'échauffement
médiatique et puis après vient bon la
réalité de la la campagne et puis le
choix des français dans les deux
derniers mois ou dans le mois et demi
qui qui qui précède l'élection chaque
fois on était soumis mais un reproche la
même pression médiatique ou la seule
question pour les régionales c'est de
savoir vous allez vous alliez avec le
front national ou avec en marche la
réalité c'est que sur nos couleurs qu'on
a gagné et très largement et notamment
par rapport au front national je
rappelle qu'ils
il était il ya six ans en tête au
premier tour dans six régions de france
là ils ont été dans une seule et avec un
score plus faible puisqu'il n'avait fait
aucune élection la mise en place et le
respect du calendrier conformément au
vote du 25 donc avec un un congrès qui
aura lieu le 4 le 4 décembre
d'ici là on met en place des dés demain
jours qui viennent une instance de
contrôle qui sera présidée par philippe
bas un comité
d'organisation et puis la mobilisation
de tous nos réseaux de nos fédérations
etc pour organiser
l'accueil de nos candidats